We all love a great story.
So this lesson should be a fun one.
But I want you to remember that students need to see
that story originates from God himself.
Again, this is another pointer to God showing students
that God exists because we have these things.
Because we have such a thing as story,
because we can tell great stories.
And as people that reflect the image of God,
we get that from him.
And it's awesome.
And your students hopefully will see that
at the end of this unit.
And a fun way to do this is to find different stories,
whether it be your own story,
or maybe some of their stories,
or someone that you know,
could be a book, could be a movie.
But you want to find within those stories,
redemptive themes, themes of salvation,
those kinds of things.
And you'd be surprised how many different stories
are actually based off of
or have biblical themes buried within them.
So now you are officially halfway through the curriculum.
You've had some time to take inventory of where you are,
whether students, where you are with your leaders
and your small groups and the community
and those types of things.
You've had a chance to step back
and take a look at all that
and see how the year is going so far.
Now it's time to evaluate.
Now this might not be something you're used to doing,
but I highly encourage it.
I think it's really, really helpful in moving forward.
So we're gonna call this your midterm.
So get ready, because you have a quiz and a test coming up
and you're gonna need, no, I'm just kidding.
You have two, I just have two suggestions.
It's super simple.
First thing is something that I've been doing
for years with students that I think is awesome
is have them do something.
I mean, instead of just having them listen
and maybe engage in discussion,
might pick out one, might pick out several,
but have some students pick one of their favorite lessons,
a favorite topic of a part of a lesson
and either teach it back, lead a discussion,
do something with it.
That's fun.
It doesn't mean they're crazy or super complicated,
but just to help you and help your leaders
get an idea of are your students digesting this
and are they able to communicate it back?
If they can accurately communicate something back to you,
they've got it.
It's a simple, easy way to determine
whether or not they're tracking with you.
You can ask them all day long and they might say yes,
but when they try to say it,
they're all over the place and they don't get it.
But if they can sort of teach it back
and then we'll kind of compel other students
and it's changing things up and it's kind of fun
and it's something different
and they can have some fun with it,
but this is a really good time to do that
now that you're about, now you are halfway through.
The second thing is take a look
at where you struggled with, right?
So you don't wanna keep moving forward
if for some reason you got stuck on something else.
So now might be a good time to think about,
well, how do I unstick myself from this particular topic?
If you have something that maybe just,
either you weren't comfortable with,
maybe they didn't get, maybe you want some reinforcements,
maybe there were some additional questions
that you just couldn't answer.
And maybe it's just a matter of you sitting down
doing some more research and figuring it out.
That'd be awesome.
Maybe it's an additional video you find someplace else
or maybe it's bringing in the experts.
Maybe it's bringing in somebody.
On our website at awyam.org,
we are gonna have for you a list of potential people
that you can get a hold of.
Can't guarantee they're gonna come,
but you can get a hold of them to see
if you can schedule a time to bring in
one of many apologetics experts to help you
or do a special event or do something to further
the sticky point or just further a discussion
that was already started.
So great job getting this first half of the year completed.
I know these first few months probably have been difficult.
There's been some topics that you had to tackle
that maybe you've been a little less than comfortable with
and some things that maybe have been challenging
for you and your students.
But I know you guys have done a phenomenal job
of getting the information to the students
and engaging with them at a high level
and making this stuff super relevant
and stressing its importance
as they continue their walk with Christ.
And if you're struggling anywhere
and for any reason on anything, please reach out to us.
We are here to help you.
You can email us, you can hit us up on Twitter or Facebook.
We have a series of videos called In Two Minutes
that we designed specifically for students.
And in the comments below those,
we invite students to ask additional questions
and through those questions,
we will continue to add additional videos
and answer additional questions.
Again, we are here to help you.
Please reach out to us
and we will help you in any way that we can.